in this lesson we're going to talk about
extended ratios so i've got an example
here for you to try go ahead and pause
the video see if you can do it on your
own and we'll go through it together it
says the angles of a triangle are in the
ratio one to two to three
find the angle measures of the triangle
okay so see if you can do this on your
own essentially what you want to do here
okay there's a little trick and once you
see the trick you know makes it a very
easy problem to solve is you just go
ahead and add in a variable like x for
example so the ratio is going to be
1x to 2x
to 3x so you can see i just add that
variable in this is still a one to two
to three ratio and then if you think of
your triangle i'll just draw a generic
triangle here this is x 2x
and 3x and we know that the angles in a
triangle all add up to 180 degrees right
so we can make an equation 1x plus 2x
plus 3x equals 180 degrees so this comes
out to 6x equals 180 degrees if we
divide everything by 6 we get x equals
30 degrees and then by putting it back
in you can see this is going to be 1
times 30 2 times 30
and 3 times 30
and those are going to be the angle
measures of your triangle so again just
knowing how to work with extended ratios
the trick or technique is basically to
add in that variable and then go ahead
and write an equation with those you
know those quantities and you've got it
so an important concept to understand
i'll see you in the next lesson